just to go through a pretty quick agenda
here we'll just go through some
introductions and we'll have our awesome
presentation by nathan stevens
and then a lot of time for q a um and
just some open discussion and networking
amongst the group too
but i do just want to make sure i note
that it is being recorded and the
session will be shared up to youtube for
anybody who missed it or if you want to
go back and and check it out um again
but for anyone who's joining this group
uh for the first time
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for
teams to share the work that they're
doing within their organizations
also teams from our studio to share some
of the work that we're doing teach
lessons learn network with each other
but really just allow us all to learn
from each other
so thank you all for making this a
welcoming community
um and if you do ever have suggestions
or general feedback i'll share a form at
the end as well
but we will have a slido link for any
questions that you have during the talk
so if
you don't want to be part of the
recording as well you could also ask
anonymous questions there too
but i'll share that in just a minute
but with that i would love to introduce
our speaker nathan stevens so nathan
will be presenting on scaling
spreadsheets with r
nathan is an enterprise architect here
at our studio
and has a background in analytics
solutions and consulting
and experience building data science
team architecting analytic
infrastructure
and also delivering innovative product
data products
so with that i will stop my share nathan
and turn it over to you great thanks
rachel it's a real honor to be uh doing
this and i appreciate you rachel setting
this up um and thanks maria for getting
this going and being an inspiration here
um really appreciate the opportunity uh
hopefully uh
i don't uh i value everyone's time we
have a lot of people on the call and so
i want to make sure that you walk away
with um
some information uh something some new
ideas something useful that you can take
with you um and if you can't i'm going
to try to entertain you to some extent
so if there's nothing here new at least
maybe there might be a few laughs along
the way
um i i should lower the bar a lot
because i'm not i'm not great at it so
so you're gonna have to like
look for the look for the humor um but
i wanna i
i've done data science for a while and
i'm sure if you can bind all the years
here it'd be you know hundreds or
thousands of years probably in doing
data analysis right
and in preparing for this analysis one
of
the
preparing for this presentation one of
the first things i did was open up excel
and start putting ideas in for my topic
about why you should use r
beyond uh just excel right so i'm
actually in excel doing work about
things about r so so that that clued me
in on like okay where where are we here
we're in this world where excel is
ubiquitous it's everywhere it was built
you know um oh you know i was going to
give i was going to pull in this whole
video about uh from this account days
right where uh guy says like they show
them visit calculator they literally
open up a wallet they're like we will
pay you anything for this account right
so like like that's back in the 70s i
think uh it's so spreadsheets have been
here for a long time they're not going
away they're incredibly useful like i
said i use them to prepare for this
presentation um what i want to do is
kind of give an overview of
this
relationship with programming languages
so
with that let me share my screen and
we'll get started
excel is not the problem it's powerpoint
that's the problem
do you want to
you know
if you want to see the knives come out
let's talk powerpoint then then the
knives come out yeah
so this will be this will be a friendly
discussion um
all right let's get into spreadsheets
with order
why do we use um why are we using excel
we use excel for a lot of things right
um but you know
in r we have this notion of wrangling
visualizing transforming analyzing
communicating insights about data which
is the exact same thing that you're
doing with with excel right so this is a
very uh business intelligence like
mindset right like and a lot of this
presentation is about like you know
making decisions influencing um you know
taking actions see results right in a in
a business setting right you can use uh
excel to build a wedding list too and
some people at our studio have used r to
build their wedding list they will go
unnamed but i know who they are um in
general we're gonna be talking about
businesses right so um there's a nice
overlap here between what you're
actually doing in the bi world between
excel and our and a lot of other
languages a lot of other tools as well
like you know quick sense or tableau or
um you know
or
matlab or sas right so um so anyway
we're on familiar territory
however
uh if we you
if you've used excel to any extent you
know that you end up with some problems
and your dilbert's boss is saying did
you see any errors on the spreadsheet
and it's like only three what are they
your data your format and your formulas
right so we know that as you use these
spreadsheets you know you kind of run
into some problems and that's
where i want to talk about how r can
address some of those problems i'm going
to actually focus on two problems today
the first one is file size okay so excel
handles kilobytes megabytes no problem
right when you start getting into like
uh the gigabytes right and tens of
gigabytes like lots of problems right it
becomes much more difficult and
do introducing large amounts of data to
excel is kind of like a fireball for me
and this
cartoon actually represents both sides
of my personality as i get into large
cell files right uh are the coals hot
yes they're very hot i'm just about to
put on the hamburgers before you do
could you toss in a can of lighter fluid
and make a giant fireball and i've got
the most boring dad in the world right
so when i like try to blow up an excel
spreadsheet it's like that you know
fireball but there's this other actor in
my head going
yeah you don't want to do this calvin
like this is not a good idea right so
um excel does have some hard limits um
so in a spreadsheet a spreadsheet is
limited by a million rows and 16 17 16
17 000 columns right hard limits um
good luck pushing on that wall right um
there are some softer limits too around
like the memory limitations like i said
earlier uh megabytes
sweet spot right tens of megabytes no
problem starting to hundreds of
megabytes a little a little more
difficult right and then you talk about
like tens of gigabytes that's that's a
no-go like that's that's no bueno right
like it's not going to be good
at least for the excel spreadsheet
now i know now i have to be careful
because i know there's some
real pros out there that are more
advanced in excel than i am and um we're
going to talk about that right we're
going to talk about that that's what's
coming up so just hold up hold your fire
okay so uh the second problem i want to
talk about is complexity right um and
complexity this is a nebulous topic
right i'm taking a multi-dimensional
space and put it into one latent factor
called complexity right and i'm gonna
i'm gonna define complexity for my own
purposes in this presentation but i
think there's some intuitive appeal here
too because like i pulled this right off
you know xkcd right the most complicated
thing on the planet it's a sprawling
excel spreadsheet built up over 20 years
by a church group in nebraska
coordinating their scheduling
we've all seen it we've all seen that
spreadsheet right that's complicated but
let's put a little bit more meat on the
bones and say what what are we talking
about by complexity well i think if you
have i think a simple workbook looks
something like this right it's like a
single data source
some summary statistics it's no data
updates it's got a few functions that
are easy to understand maybe you throw
in a drop down list for you know fancy
you know use case show off a little bit
you have a couple pivot tables and just
a just a handful of sheets maybe just
one right or maybe you know six or seven
not too many a complex workbook but by
contrast would be many data sources with
advanced algorithms built into it
somehow right and then dynamically
updating the data on a regular basis
with you know formulas you hit f2 and
like the thing drops down fills up half
the screen all the formulas are nested
like seven times over there's visual
basic scripts right in the background
you've got several pivot tables or
charts they're all sharing data so
they're all kind of like linked to the
same spreadsheet and you've got you know
maybe dozens or hundreds of spreadsheets
like those things are terrifying right
you open that's the spreadsheet you're
like there's no end to the number of
spreadsheets in this workbook that's
complicated right so that's what i mean
by complex right there's this wide
spectrum right you can kind of fill in
the blanks
so
why scale spreadsheets with r well r can
handle far more data than excel so
in excel the sweet spots really in that
megabyte range and are the sweet spots
in the gigabyte range right so like
handling a gigabyte or a 10 gigabytes no
problem in r no problem at all um r can
also handle much more complexity than
excel because it's code based right so a
complex workbook in excel equals a
simple script in r so i'm going to come
back to this previous slide here for a
second so this complex workbook over
here on this other column
that is what we call a simple r script
right so that's simple for r or in fact
that's why you want to use r because r
is really good at these things right so
i'm going to show that in my
demonstration that r actually can do
these things really quite easily
so simple in r equals complex in
in excel
all right so
if you put these two dimensions on two
axes right
and you say
i've got a simple design a complex
design and a small s and then on one and
small size and large size on on the
other axis
then excel fits neatly in my opinion my
estimation around these small
file sizes with simple designs no
problem that's great that's why i was
using them to prepare for this
presentation i was actually inputting
the data right to itself so that's great
pull it up put some data in there and
monkey around beautiful
um when things get really complicated or
really large so we're thinking like that
previous thing like multiple levels and
data sources and update all this stuff
right um i would argue r's really good
at that right and and can you use excel
in that world
yeah
yeah i mean yeah you i've seen some
really creative uses but r is r is
really good at that i don't really want
to talk about these quadrants any more
than i already had what i really want to
talk about is the off diagonals i want
to look at
where when you have something that's
fairly small file size but very
complicated
like when would you
think about using r instead of excel
and when you have something that's
really
large files a large file size but it's
very very simple data structure just
like you know one table that's just a
little too big like
where do you think about using r in that
dimension so i'm very interested in this
boundary right and defining this
boundary at least that's what this talk
is about it's like what does this
boundary look like
when does it make sense to start
thinking about maybe leaving the excel
world and trying
some functions in r so that's what we're
going to talk about today i've got two
problems i'm going to show you and the
first one in each quadrant the first one
is going to be where the files are too
large
but the design is very very simple
so i have to
stop this presentation
to the web
okay so the data the first data we're
going to use
is uh popular baby names from the social
security administration that are state
specific this is a zipped file if i
click on this to start downloading as
can see i've downloaded it four times
right it's 21 megabytes right downloads
very quickly
and if you open it up it looks something
like
that
it's like
this uh names by state this is the zip
here
unzip it it's got 50 files and well
indeed washington dc
um
and uh if you open up
arkansas for example yep you get this uh
this file right pretty straightforward
you can open these up into excel
which i did
and uh this is what it looks like in
itself
okay so here's arkansas
and
i loaded up every single state into
excel and i did some googling about like
how to do that the best and i came to
the conclusion it's probably just
easiest if i just do this by hand it
took somewhere between five and ten
minutes to load everything in every
state now
all of these things are fine
um for
each state because they all fit so if i
come over here to come over here to
um
arkansas
you can see that there was about three
uh what 30 000 names something like that
30 000 names no problem right
um but there's some there's a lot of
issues here right off the bat right so
uh
the first issue i already mentioned it i
had to like load them all up that was
kind of plain but one time cost right so
that's done but now i don't have any
headers
so i need to go back and i want to put
the headers in now i've got to put
headers into 50
files and that's that's a pain i didn't
bother to do that because that sounds
like a nightmare waiting to happen right
um when i put all the data together yeah
it was 21 megabytes zipped but when it
was unzipped it was 128 megabytes and
that's what it is in the excel file too
it's around 120 megabytes and that's
large enough to get the spinning wheel
on the auto updates that required to get
the you know escape on the council
because i'll be using it and it'll just
stop
you know working
um
then you've got things like um
you know the
um
pivot tables here
are uh you know one state at a time
uh that seems to be okay
except uh i found something really
interesting in this process uh when i
got to california
um
i was looking for names
and it turns out this drop down menu has
a list a cap of about 10 000 names and
in california there's 20 000 names in
this thing so so i can just get up to
carry and then i can't get any i can't
get beyond that right um and so that's
that's frustrating um you know and i'm
just starting to hit some rough edges
here but the the real
hard edge is like i don't really want to
do the state base i want to combine
everything and then analyze across
states and this thing is over 6 million
records long it's not going to fit into
a worksheet right so i have to figure
out some other way to handle it now
there are many ways to handle i
mentioned before you got bi tools right
you've got other programming languages
you can pull up python right if you want
to but this is not a talk about python
just to talk about r so i want to show
you what this would look like in r
okay so again
one of the big issues here is i can't
load all the data into
let me show you what it looks like just
to load in one state
if i come into import daystat
so if you've never seen our studio i
don't know if anyone's new to our studio
but this is this is our studio right you
get the r prompt download your script up
high you've got some tools over here on
the right
so i'm going to go ahead and read in the
data i'm going to browse for the data
i'm going to go here and pull up
arkansas again
um
and uh
i'm i keep saying arkansas ak is ak
alaska ak's alaska isn't it so i should
know better i've been to alaska i've
never been to arkansas
um
okay so we're going to pull up alaska
and notice the headers are off right we
don't have a header in there so we're
going to get rid of the headers
okay good now we just have generic
headers um this is messed up too right
uh this is supposed to be male female
and the f and the female the computer
thinks it's a false for some reason so
we're going to change this to a
character
there you go now you're male female and
you can see that uh it actually uh wrote
the code for me over here right it
just did it all for me which is really
nice so i'll go ahead and import
there we go and uh and there's my code
so i can get that code in there really
easily
and i can do some fun things like i can
do um
let's do um
i can filter this thing right i can say
i want to filter ak which is the name of
the data set and i'll say like
name equals jesse okay
uh what did i do wrong oh because
there's no name there's no headers on
this one so it's got to be uh
x4 okay
so there's my filtered data set and i
can plot it if i want to um
i'm gonna do a gg plot and i can do
some
statics here
do
i want to do year which is
x3
by
count which is x5
and i want to do a line plot
there you go there's a line
now it looks different than the
um
the one that we did in excel
because
excel one
actually had categorical names on the
axis right so we have to fix that right
these years are not um say it goes from
1923 to 1926
in the same increments that it went from
1992 to 1993. so this is the more
accurate
view of the data right
okay so this is great so i can come in
here and kind of tool around a little
bit and use few little art things to
like you know manipulate my day but that
was my cut my my hard edge my hard edge
was reading all the data so let me let
me read in all the data and the way i do
that
i'm going to use
the vroom package because the room
package makes this really easy it's a
very good package for like loading in
lots of data so if you have like many
gigabytes that's great we just have 128
it's going to be lightning fast
i'm going to go ahead and
grab all the files in that directory so
these are all the files and the room
command says just take the files
and um
take the column and add a column header
right so i don't have to like do that 50
times
that's a really simple command let's go
ahead and see what broom gives us
so it says that we have
6 000 records right
five columns
and this tells me a little about those
columns
and i can uh yeah i can take a look at
that if i want to or i can save this so
i'm actually going to write this back to
file i'm going to write this as a csv
won't take too long
yeah it's cranking away great piece of
cake right super fast super easy no
problem i now have one file that's
concatenated to all of them uh no
mistakes in the code because i wasn't
doing anything copying and pasting right
it's a simple concatenation say well hey
i can do concatenation of files in any
number of ways right it's like yes yes
you can but here's the thing like we're
just going to make uh we're going to
jump right into some exploratory data
analysis now one thing that excel has
that r doesn't have is this notion of
notebooks right so notebooks are
formats that contain the
pros and the code and the results of the
code all in the same document and
they're really useful because it lets
you keep track of your thought process
right so if you go back later you can
see why um what you were thinking and
doing
which is why it's called a notebook
right so leonardo da vinci was famous
for his notebooks you know
back in the day
they're still popular today and um so
this is what an r notebook looks like
um this is um
oh that's my speaker notes
yes that's right i was going to show you
my speaker notes because this is where
we come into
uh yeah so here's my uh data analysis i
showed you and then the files so i wrote
a notebook to keep track of my speaker
notes right you're seeing the the
process that i went through to to do
this um there's the room right that we
just did and then we get to we get to
this one here so i put in the spaceballs
if you ever see spaceballs they get to
the
now
situation where they're looking at the
movie in real time and he says you're
looking at now everything that happens
now is happening now right and brooke
miranda says this is now what happened
to them and he says we passed then when
now
when will then be now
soon right so that's coming soon
all right so let me show you the
notebook i really wanted to show you so
here's the setup um
i can uh load my packages in here now
for the you know the people who have
been using r for a while
you might already have some preferences
for how you load in your data um i've
showed you two here already the read csv
is the is part of the you know read r
package the room is packaged is really
cool it's part of the tidy verse um
there's this other really popular one
called f read right and f reads
lightning fast it's super good so you
just pick which one you want right um
and there's more than that but these are
the three of the most popular ones um
you know if you have lots of data these
become really important distinctions
right
okay so
now i'm going to do my data analysis now
i just want to backtrack for one second
back to this um
graphic here
come back here
when you go
into this larger file
size area where
you know data becomes largish
almost universally you're going to
default back to something that's like
sql
no matter what tool you're using it's
going to be look very sequel like right
and that's no different with r so in r
i'm going to use a tool called d plier
and d player looks like sql because it
uses the notion of verbs
and this is what that looks like right
so i've got a filter statement instead
of a where right i have a group by
statement
a summarized statement which is like you
know the
aggregate you know variables and the
select statement or the window um
variables um and then i do actually have
a select statement here at the end right
so this is how you would manipulate data
very sql like way of doing the data so
we'll go ahead and run that code
i don't think there's much of an output
there
and now we'll just kind of monkey around
a little bit we'll look at most popular
names from 1996 and what happened to
those popular names right
um
oh now what's going on
well
that would not
be a surprise without
a live demo without some error
okay that must be a that must be a bug
in the visual editor so i've been um
this is what uh the documents typically
look like uh in our in our markdown in
our notebooks this is the default view
what i was showing you earlier was what
is a new feature called the visual
editor so you can kind of toggle between
these two and visual editors is
formatted it's going to give you a more
like jupiter notebook feel to it
and for some reason it's not
showing me my
output so the way you start you solve
this is you refresh your session and
start over
but i'm just going to go ahead and stick
with the old uh
the old notebook i think here and just
stick with the old version
there you go most popular names 1996.
and um which is uh emily jessica matthew
and michael okay
and then if you look at the most popular
names leading up in 2020 last year the
most popular names were
ava emma liam noah oliver and olivia
and olivia just going strong just going
strong okay
so
um
yeah and this shows you the run up so
olivia is this purple line right and you
can see it's been going strong for quite
a while i've been talking your name
all right and then you can look at these
shared names right so i'm going to take
a look at these names that maybe are
shared by both um
they're multi-gendered right names
so you can just a quick question is it
um would you be able to enlarge the font
size a little bit
oh is it is it kind of small let's um
how's that
thank you
yep and then
while i'm asking you questions one other
question because i know it's on a lot of
people's mind is will you share this
script with us after yeah yeah yeah it's
on github already it's in the notes and
yeah it's all there for you cool thank
you
okay so basically you get to this and
you're like okay this is cool like uh
you know i might have something to say
about this right i might want to do
something so i'm gonna uh run build an
application um this is a shiny
application this is not a shiny demo so
i'm just gonna leave it at that this is
how you can build applications in our
i'm going to run that app and show you
what that looks like
okay so in the shiny app
when i've blown it up so much i can't
really see it so let me um let me open
up a window here
there we go
okay so this is jesse
and i can go ahead and add in like
colorado and california right
and that's the name of jesse and you can
see that jessie's sharing mostly a male
name
right
and uh there there's some females named
jesse as well so this is what the female
view you know looks like here
and
the cool thing here is like all of the
names are in here i can pick any name i
want i
picked uh jessie because
for some reason i was thinking about
uncle jesse when i told the name and i
was like okay jesse
was popular right about here
so good good job john stamos you pretty
much killed the name
so
um if you want to pick a different name
though like
uh rebecca which i think was his love
interest
you can see that you know you can pick
any name you want which is really cool
this is a very simple app now if you
want to share this application online
you do this with um you know our studios
product which is our studio connect and
so you can publish this thing with a
push of a button and then share it with
other people and that becomes very
powerful tool to use in the enterprise
right you can also
share the notebook right so here's the
notebook that's also on connect and uh
this will allow you to keep track of
your content not other people to
collaborate to or to see what you're
doing
so that in a nutshell is size i'm going
to keep moving here because i'm going to
run out of time
the next thing i want to talk about was
this quadrant here around
where the workbook is too complex so
we're going to toggle over and talk
about
something file that's pretty
small but
the workbook ends up being really
complicated so let me do that here come
back to excel
new data set okay this is a new data set
this is about um customer um
data
this is called a growth equation that
breaks down revenue into constituted
parts and it's got these cool little
drop downs right where i can choose a
segment i can choose a metric and i can
either be your you know year-to-date or
whatnot and i worked really hard on this
thing this thing took a long time to
build i mean we're talking weeks to
build this thing right um and this is
actually the simplified view it was in
the in all of its glory it was actually
a lot more sophisticated than this but
basically you pull some some data in the
free period you pull some data in the
post period you write some
you know lookups here some offsets to
like get the data that you need based on
the inputs here in the you know
parameters
um table and then you pretty it up here
and you do that every week and you mail
it out and uh you know people that like
it go oh cool they copy it and paste it
and they use it too right now
there was a problem with this um thing
that i ran into and and that was that um
it was really hard to maintain
like it was always changing and any
change was very difficult to make and
sometimes the data were really hard to
get right um because the data were
coming in such a way that um even the
smallest changes were hard to track down
so this thing that um
was uh you know kind of my pride and joy
it ended up being um kind of this task
master monster for me you know um i
created this beast um and it's so much
so that uh well anyway i'll just leave
it at that the best of attention
sometimes don't plan out play out well
and unfortunately the the the bottom
line here is that um
you know this took a lot of time
and ultimately yielded
you know the well the best result here
was i became very good at excel so so
there was that but uh like from the
business value perspective i think the
business value was a little bit off
so um
let me show you what this looks like in
r
all right
so an r
this is another um application a little
hard to see here but um
this is this is the application it's not
it's it's really not that bad it's uh
it's it's not that bad of a shiny
application let me go ahead and run it
it's over here there we go
cool so i can choose my segment right i
can choose i can do all the same stuff
right and i've got my output here which
is really nice
and i can download the data set right
and this is really cool because if i
open up this thing
i actually get back to the excel output
right with the chart and the data and i
actually get the data that i use to
create those metrics here so that's
really that that's really nice because
then you're just pulling the exact data
that you want and the users can do it
themselves
now
again this is something that you're
probably going to want to publish to
connect and this is what it looks like
in connect this is a
you know tool where everybody can access
it and and honestly you know at this
point this is really fancy and nice but
i've kind of gone above and beyond
you know
shiny apps are
sexy and interesting because they're you
know interactive they're reactive right
and people like that and it's great but
it doesn't have to be that way and there
are some negatives to this as well
because getting this report means i have
to like you know get in here to the
application and then get what i want and
download it
it's like sometimes you just want to
email out your results right it's like
this is the report email it out
you know executives they don't want to
look at an app anyway they just live in
their email so
so in that situation you use a report
and the report here
looks like this
this is the arm markdown and this is
actually a simpler
thing to do
because you put all of your parameters
here at the top and the header
and then all of your stuff is here now
now one of the cool things i really like
about this script is is stuff like this
this shows me all my formulas right like
anybody can read this anyone on this
call can read this it's like how do you
define um
let's see like uh what is it like items
uh
like spend pre right well it's the
dollars pre divided by the item spree
it's the pre those that's that's how
that's calculated
that's a really nice way to look at your
code right so if you want to knit this
thing um you can come up here to knit
with parameters
you can just choose
you know
the things here like
the shiny app this is actually a shiny
gadget and
kind of get this thing and it will give
you the report that you want and this is
actually a little easier to maintain and
if you put this into if you put the same
report into connect
you can
do this really cool thing where you can
like email yourself so this is that rook
same report and connect
um i'm gonna send that email you can
come up here you can choose the
parameters that you want so it's all
cool right so
but you don't even need connect to do
this actually like you can easily like
just generate these reports um
from the code um and uh
and this is what they look like on
the mail system right so they come
across looking like this where you get
this nice email body
and
you get the down the
attachments here
okay
so
this report uh this code here let me
come back to the code
this code here
i dusted off that thing that took like
weeks and weeks to build and i recreated
it from the ground up in r in about six
hours
from six weeks to six hours literally
okay so when we talk about complexity
that's what i'm talking about like
writing the code here like are that that
things complex workbooks just become
simpler
and they become more i would argue to
become more accurate too at least in my
experience but they become a lot simpler
to do in r
okay so
in summary here
how do you
scale
spreadsheets in r
boy that takes a long time
again
i got to do a presentation on powerpoint
okay how do you scale spreadsheets are
by using powerful coding tools that make
your work reproducible and communicate
with apps and notebooks
so if um
you know
you're ever in a situation
right if you've ever been in a situation
where you feel like your hands are being
burned
because in your excel you know notebooks
or you're like sweating to get through
the excel um notebooks i would suggest
that hey maybe there's a better way
right maybe there's another tool and
here uh
zog has a stick right so zog's actually
figured out a better way to deal with
the fire right
so
um this boundary hopefully this boundary
is a little bit
clearer i think
i i know i drew it as a hard line i
actually think that's a pretty wide
spectrum right um i think there's a
pretty big difference between you know
what spot you're going to move from
excel to r
but hopefully this presentation has
helped clarify um like why you would use
r instead of excel um even in the event
you're not doing like a bunch of random
forests right even an event where you
just need to do some you know regular
old data science exploration
so the last thing i will say is that in
this r space
you know you're doing data science you
know you can do data science in excel
right you can do it in r and excel is
a great tool it's got it's turing
complete right it's got power
um query built into it right you can
publish things to power bi
uh you know you can um
you've got the visual basic and the back
end which is not really my cup of tea
but
it has a programming language and it
works and it can be tracked you can
version control itself you can do all
those things um in excel
the nice one of the nice things about r
is it really clarifies when you're using
the code and
um i'm going to suggest to you that you
know in data science the source for all
your results really is your code it's
not
it's not the report it's not the output
but it's the process that you use to get
the code so in excel if you think about
excel and you like share some output
from excel or like in powerpoint
so you take some pivot tables from excel
put them into powerpoint it's like
that's nice that output is really
valuable but the source for that
was the process that you went through to
get that information it was
querying my your microstrategy with a
specific query and then loading it up
and then doing some manipulations doing
some cleaning like doing some
explorations building some charts
that whole process is where the value is
in data science and when you use things
like our script or you know code or
scripting language like you get that
part as a natural part of the process
okay so i've got some references here
and i'm going to pause and um
see what questions there are
i'm happy to help read the questions um
and just wanted to let people know again
that we do have the slido link for
questions too
so you can either ask with your name and
or ask it live or ask anonymously
but christina i see you just asked a
question
around
what if the executive wants the report
for every combination of parameters
do you have strategies to iterate
through them and generate a full pdf
report
and christina feel free to jump in and
add any other context too if you want to
yeah so if your executive wants every
combination
it sounds like your executive wants to
do data science
so you can build uh tools for that date
that executive to do the data science
and that's what um you would do with the
shiny application right so you build a
shiny application and you you put that
out there um
yeah it sounds like you have a very
interesting executive my experience as
executives usually they want the bottom
line um and so it might be an
opportunity here to you know help the
the executive do some of his own
analysis
well
this is it's christine is my wife but
this is casey uh the
so what we actually do are tableau
dashboards but then we also have to
publish
all like we have to do all the filters
for like every combination basically and
then we have this like c plus program
that
takes web shots of all of them and like
puts this report together and it's a
really
complicated process
that's what that's kind of what i was
getting at with that oh that's so
interesting i actually i actually took
that part of this presentation out um
but i gave this so i can send you a link
another version of this presentation
actually does take the web shots um puts
them into powerpoint presentations
programmatically and would allow you to
do something like that i i think that
the
um so tableau is a great tool right
tableau's tableau and our our studio
products are basically solving the same
problem it's just that r is doing it
with code and tableau is not so i i'd be
surprised if there were things that
you're doing in tableau that you
couldn't do above and beyond with r uh
but the the thing that you mentioned
where you're talking about like
programmatically pulling all
combinations and doing web shots putting
them in a presentation yes that's all
possible and i've done it
yeah
yeah definitely that other link yeah
good thank you
thank you
and uh one question i saw that quickly
got two upvotes on slido leo asked could
you please show a quick step by step to
achieve that awesome email with the
graph and formatted table oh you want to
see how the email was created
yeah yeah i can do that and i should go
back and i'll do the powerpoint thing
too here in a second
um
[Music]
i appreciate the interest in the code i
um
[Music]
let's see
what did i do
speaker notes
here we go
okay so in the arm markdown version
it's going to look like
this
i'm going to say compose the email right
here and uh what's the name of this
package richard you remember
blastula
is the package that we're looking for
and then um dt is another one that
you're looking for like the
um no no gt gt not dt's data table uh gt
grammar of tables and blastula but uh
this is where i put in the
um
subject line
right and this is where i define the um
plot
and then when i compose the email these
looks this might look like comments but
this is all being recognized by r right
so this is like actually pulling in the
things in r and inserting them into the
content of the document and you can read
all about that in the blastula um help
site and then on the our markdown um
side you have to attach uh the subject
line here so this is the subject line
this is the body these are images and
these are attachments so the xls file
gets attached here in the r markdown
file
that makes sense so what that's going to
this is all the email now i also make
the xls file here available
as a link to the report and that's this
in our studio connect feature but um
because i can make that work really
nicely but
this is the
this is i think what you're looking for
i i wanted to just briefly mention i
since i didn't take out the powerpoint
thing i just want to make sure that
that you're aware that when you do like
a presentation here
um our markdown
if you come here to presentation on our
markdown one of the options is
powerpoint
so you can actually generate powerpoints
here and then in
powerpoint uh going back to web shots
you can put web shots in here to like
you know pick up the things that you're
trying to insert into powerpoint which
is kind of cool
what else
um i see a conversation
in the zoom chat right now and um
cassandra asks what level of security is
available when using our studio and a
shiny app
because they work in the treasury with
sensitive banking information
and i see someone else also works in
banking too
yeah so we take we take security very
seriously at our studio um
it's always been my so i've
been able to
be around for a while and i used to
process all the security reviews when i
first started it was a tiny company so i
had to go through all that but it became
very clear to me early on that we don't
have a company without
secure software so i'm not saying that
we've got everything you know
figured out because it's an ongoing
process but i will tell you that you
know we have
onboarded um hundreds of customers that
have had a variety of security needs
and we haven't lost any deals
specifically because security so if i
come into support here
i do uh
security
uh there's package security uh
security package downloads i think this
is probably
a good place so
ssl right
um
cross-origin um resource sharing
right um
yeah so if there's a specific questions
too i'm always happy to
take that offline and help connect you
with the right person internally i'll
just put my email there too if that's
useful
yeah no i think the general question is
you know can i trust you know my shiny
applications and keep in mind that
normally these shiny applications are
used for internal purposes um
like normally uh you are like you're
putting this behind your firewall so
that's usually the standard you're
looking for is like is it secure behind
that firewall
thanks nathan
um i see another anonymous question that
was excel may be considered as
interactive app for data analysis
how do you help excel users successfully
transition to a shiny app developer
well yeah you're in luck i mean there
are a lot of resources around learning
to do shiny so if you go to
was it shinydogstudio.com that's a great
place to get started um the the creator
of shinee is joe chang and um and
chinese 10 years old now it's been
around for a while but the cool thing
about shiny is that
it was designed to uh fail nicely so joe
talks about the pit of success right so
you might make him this mistake but
shiny is going to be nice to you you
know when you make that mistake it'll
give you it'll like find something else
to do it won't or it'll give you a
warning or you know it'll
like help you try to figure out the best
way to do it so the way if you're
transitioning to shiny um be nice to
yourself start simple and then just
follow the patterns and fall into that
bit of success i say that myself because
i'm not the
world's best shiny app developer
my background's in big data right and so
not as opposed to front end you know
application design um but i have learned
um the
just dealing with going with the
patterns going with the flow you're
gonna have a pretty gentle ride with
with shiny and if you do have problems i
go to community.rstudio.com
there's a lot of resources on the
community site about doing shiny and you
can ask questions like you would like in
a stack overflow type of situation
i think it can also be helpful to check
out the shiny gallery too and i'll put
that in the chat definitely
but it can give you a good starting
point if you see something that you're
it's kind of like what you want to do
and go from there
i will point out one thing that's
interesting about shiny is that reactive
nature is very similar to the excel
paradigm right so in excel you change
one cell and it just trickles through
the whole spreadsheet and can just have
massive changes to the the experience
shiny is the same way you'll change one
thing and it will just reactively like
uh percolate through the entire
application it's pretty it's cool it's
cool stuff
another question
on slido from josh was tools such as
github sql power bi tableau excel
curious your thoughts on these tools
that they as they don't seem to be
emphasized enough with respect to their
use in the workplace
these tools
i'm struggling with that question a
little bit because in my in my
you know i deal with customers on a
daily basis and it seems like
everybody's using those tools so uh we
get so many questions about that and sql
has been our has just been such a
dominant
paradigm for so long i was i was joking
with my friends like i i did uh
you know i've worked with no no sql
databases for quite a while right like
not no structured things like like you
know tableau or you know redis and
they're always there's always some sort
of sequelness around it you're like hi
right it's not even sql but they put hql
on top of it so so i think sql is one of
the most enduring paradigms in
technology that i'm aware of um and uh
don't bet against it i would i i think
it's great i think i think everyone
should i sequel's just a skill that's
great to have i i do think i don't want
to riff too long on this because i could
go on but the um
i think one of the problems with sql in
general with with the world is like very
few people
get formalized sql training i i was
lucky enough to get that right so i
learned sql on the job like like nobody
in academia talks about sql right then
you go to shouldn't say nobody but
nobody in my experience academia ever
mentioned anything about sql and then i
go into the job and that's all anybody's
doing so i i learned sql that way but
then i actually did take a training
class on sql and then talked about the
query planners right and uh
you know other clauses that you know
maybe not so familiar with and
and uh and window functions in the
different size of it that was very
useful so if you if you really wanted to
do something hardcore you can get
formalized training i don't think it's
necessary but if it makes you feel like
more of an expert or feel better about
your skills like those things are out
there
josh let us know if we missed anything
in that question too feel free to jump
in
if if i could um kind of just clarify i
think you did end up touching on what i
meant um
there's a limit on the words or letters
you can use but um so
with r i learned a lot about r through
school
um barely was exposed to any of the
other tools so it seems now that i'm
backtracking to
learn the other tools to
match my use with r but i barely use r
in the workplace
oh okay yeah that makes sense that makes
a lot of sense so um are you miss
yeah are you
missing r wanting r to integrate with
those other solutions
yeah i guess i'm just wondering your
thoughts on uh the emphasis around the
other tools because they do seem like
sql
um and excel seems like something you'll
want to especially excel mastered at
before you master r
based on its use in the workplace
[Music]
i think r is a niche programming
language mostly used by scientists who
are seeking the truth and
uh if you still go to the r
project page today it'll say it's a
language for statistical computing and
visualization and
the you know how many companies are
sitting around thinking i just i mean i
need some statistical compute and
visualization software around here
that's not what they're thinking they've
got data they've got operations they've
got bi they've got these big systems
they've got these enterprise
requirements right so it's not a
surprise that like in academia you're
using r to do science and learning and
then the industry is using more
enterprise tools that doesn't surprise
me at all i think one of the yeah
i could keep going on here i think one
of the reasons why i wanted to join our
studio was to help bridge that gap but
um
i think uh yeah i could you josh you and
i should grab a cup of coffee and talk
i i i hear you i
yeah that sounds great you know your
situation man yeah
i'd love to jump in on that party if i
can because i'm a similar boat
i'll schedule a virtual coffee if anyone
wants to come here
because that's exactly what i'm
struggling with
what are you struggling with maria
yeah well that's exactly the gap they
get they get that you have to evaluate
yeah the gap like that we're talking
about the gap between like uh we're
talking about evangelizing r and showing
like why r is relevant in the enterprise
so we're getting that
yeah yeah
well rachel that's been a good fight for
a long time do you want to do you want
to respond to that you're you're doing a
lot of that work right now i really
appreciate it
yeah definitely that's that's exactly
what i want to help teams with so i'm
going to say in the chat right now
message me if you want to get in on that
virtual coffee
but we should we should set that up and
chat more about it i don't want to kind
of overtake this talk with that but
maybe it should be another topic
i wrote a post of many years ago when i
first joined our study about making our
legitimate in your organization and the
tenets of that was to allocate was to
make a decision and allocate resources
so you're looking for a stakeholder
usually someone very senior in your
organization to say we will consider r
to be an analytic standard and we're
going to support it just like we would
sql or these other tools that we're
talking about and then if you can get
out resources allocated to them whether
it be like you know like a server like
money resources or software
or you get uh individuals like saying
we're gonna train these individuals on
those things that's what you're looking
for right and that's a natural process
in most organizations to recognize
standards and um they're just because r
is fairly small it just hasn't gone
through that process there's an
assumption that r is
um that data sciences things that
people do on their laptops with free
software right and i think that greatly
undermines the value of data science um
i think that and it's you know josh you
point out
what about tableau right and what about
power bi powerbi is a little difference
because of microsoft right so microsoft
doing different things but you know all
these other tools well if you brought
tableau in the organization somebody
went up in there and said we're going to
make tableau
analytics standard for this organization
we're going to allocate resources for it
you have to do the same thing with the r
programming language you have to say
like this is this should be legit um but
that's that's all in that post i know
that rachel yeah
i'm going to stop talking now
no i'm happy to keep that conversation
going but nathan i was actually i
actually didn't even tell you this yet
but i was going through that post trying
to think about how we could revamp that
um
and so
i may as well just share it with you all
here and
figure if you have comments on things
that nathan and i could include there or
things that would be useful
um
but it's based off of nathan's original
article on making our legitimate part of
your your company yeah so i'd actually
i'll go ahead who's talking maria oh
yeah that that was that was me sending
email to rachel because uh that's that
is exactly what i'm seeing like
we all have that picture or like you
know our person like you know in glasses
like you're just just doing some really
awesome things which nobody really needs
but we don't really realize that it's
like just one hand away like a lots of
things are much so much easier there
i think most organizations want to do
things i think
you said like nobody needs i my my
experience is that most organizations
aren't very data-driven right and
there's a spectrum and um but they want
to be and they know that it's relevant i
think going through the process of
saying like you know r you take all the
emotions out of it and say like you have
a business to run right we're talking
just enterprise we have a business to
run r is a competitive advantage it
brings in great people it allows you to
do these technologies it needs support
right you you're already using c-sharp
and you're using
some python and you're using java why
not use r and those are those are
arguments that you can win i i've done
it
i mean that's been my history i've done
this multiple times with past
organizations you can you can win those
arguments um because it makes sense
right it's like um you take the motion
the people out they would say like hey
we we need this thing right
and uh you know organizations will
struggle a little bit because they don't
a lot of them don't get data science we
don't understand what you guys are doing
right but um that's changing that's all
changing right like that's um
you know ai algorithm or like common
vernacular now in
the world like you know
my grandma's passed on but if i had a
grandma still she would know what ai was
and she would be pretty kicked off about
algorithms for some reason
both of them are not data driven at all
and for them it's one extra step that
they need to do and you know like people
are lazy they don't really want to do
extra step
if they can like
if they don't have to so before they
realize all the benefits they need to do
effort
yeah yeah there's usually some sort of
fulcrum and getting that um
executive sponsor is key like if there's
no executive sponsor no one's willing to
actually say yes that's what we're going
to do then you really you're back in
that you're back in the um the guerrilla
warfare right you're just back in there
like doing stuff and
you know throwing sweet against the wall
and hoping it sticks right
and um i have to say like if you're in
that organization
there there are better organizations
than that right like like if you're
looking to like make an impact make a
difference and improve your skills like
why would you want to be in an
organization that didn't value data
science right um because that's
i don't know again things have changed
like when i was starting my career i
just had to find a job somewhere that
and
and data science and modeling we're only
known to a very small group of people
you're just like looking for those
people i
i've looked at job listings all over the
place and there's like a ton of
opportunities now so um it's still
changing but
i don't yeah anyway i don't get
organizations that you know just
don't want to give their data scientists
any resources so i'm like
like maybe you don't want to be a part
of that organization that's just that's
that's my feeling
so better organizations is our hiring
what's that who
i said if there's better organizations
is our hiring
do you mean our studio yes our studio
has hired a ton of people like almost a
new person is coming in almost every day
right now yeah so check the job listings
and yeah
offer internships to international
students but lots of students here that
sitting in waiting for that and like you
just some sort of downgrading like a way
you have to pay your versus not have to
pay
well i will say that um we don't do a
lot of data science at r studio right
because we're not a data we're not a
data organization where we build
software right so that's our our output
is software not not data
so if you think about the things i
showed you today like the tracker you
know like the customer data like yeah we
don't have that type of data
uh nathan i know we're a little bit over
but there's still quite a few questions
i was wondering if it's okay
yeah i'm happy to hang on here this has
been really uh
yeah really rewarding in ways that i
can't possibly explain right now
thank you thank you so much nathan and
um
also on that topic of like hiring and
companies that use r as well
on
community.ourstudio.com there is also
like a jobs and gigs section where a lot
of our
customers and open source or pro
post their jobs um but also for people
who are in this position of trying to
convince internally you are definitely
not alone
so
i don't think the only answer is is
going somewhere else so would love to to
chat more about
how we can help with that too
but
one of the questions
from earlier nathan was what packages do
you recommend for importing excel files
well the yeah the easy one was uh you
know
uh
for importing excel files
oh geez
i should have done my homework to see
what's out there now uh the there wasn't
there like a read xls and then there's
like an xlsx package as well
um
yeah you know that's a that's a miss my
presentation because i was showing how
to read in the flat files but
yeah just reading those things are
pretty straightforward let me um let's
see everyone in the chat is confirming
that it was it is read excel
so it's really okay so
um if i come in here to environment
import data set
from excel
yeah read excel is the is the one that's
used by default
there are there are others i thought
there was an xlsx package at some point
but
that's the one
that's the one that our studio obviously
recommends
um and then another question from
earlier was
can you version control excel i think
maybe we mentioned there's
the one i'm familiar with is a paid
solution though so you actually have to
like subscribe to it it's an enterprise
solution which makes sense right because
excel is an enterprise tool like you
have to pay for it so
i i kind of agree with that that's one
of the nice things about r is that it's
it is free right so if you want to use
it you can get started easily um but
yeah there's ways yeah there are tech
there are tools to do that i i can't
recommend them because i haven't used
them um but last
a few months ago they released some new
function uh that made it turing complete
you know so it's like it's like excel is
there for forever and it's not just
excel either right it's also google
sheets and um it's also open office
right so it's like you actually have
three you know spreadsheet platforms to
choose from that are
very common
i need them let me go if i just come
quickly sure my uh my experiences i've
been using r and armagnal for three
years using it in the enterprise
business i first started people
introducing uh
getting them to know r
but that was a little step
too big but once i introduced them to
our markdown
they could see the link with excel very
easily very straightforward and they
love our markdown and
it connects with them with excel
because you can work in the archings
and generate nice reports easily
do it step by step
and that is my experience and how i use
it now in the enterprise i use it in the
oil and gas i use it in the marketing
business is they have these erp systems
sap microsoft dynamics and when they
have to do reporting we do systems that
is very cumbersome
and when they use
our markdown they already extract the
data
from the backend put it in a small
database access the data with
uh are markdown then it is for them
easy-peasy really they can generate
fantastic reports and they love it
at least my experience
yeah i appreciate that feedback i'd be
really so i showed the visual editor
today on the demo it broke at one point
which was unfortunate it's new i'd be
curious to know your feedback
introducing these same people the visual
editor if that actually made things even
better for them yes yes they like it
yeah but uh they don't like r but they
like our markdown
they love armando
well i mean our mark down i mean you've
got our code chunks inside of our
markdown so like you can't really use
our markdown without r right like
there's got to be yes but you're saying
they don't like the r script they'd
rather yes yeah they don't like they are
scribbly like they are marginally fine
because it is far easier to understand
to connect with excel how things work
yeah i like it i like it because um
you
i've just had too many experiences where
i wrote r code and i came back six
months later and i couldn't understand
what the heck i was thinking like i
hardly recognized it was me you know and
our markdown at least gives you some
opportunity to say this is what i'm
thinking this is why i'm doing this this
is what you should expect here um and
yeah that that's really valuable to just
to me personally right like me as a
coder
and then if you layer on all the things
that are beneficial to other people
and what i also like is about the
different output formats that you can
easily generate with arm of them
yeah html you may can make a dashboard
you can make a pdf you can make whatever
you wish
yeah i showed the powerpoint i showed
the html but yeah the pdf was really
nice and
yeah you're right thanks for the thanks
for the plug yeah i see there's a
comment here about uh our java
i kind of agree with that one that was a
that's real pain hopefully uh i try to
avoid or java when i can't
i do the the one area of java that i
have a hard time avoiding a spark spark
depends on java and and guess what spark
and java spark is kind of difficult yeah
part because of java
um nathan for the
slides that you shared will i be able to
share that with the recording as well
yeah of course you have those hosted
somewhere okay absolutely absolutely
yeah um
can i can i put one thing i couldn't get
into the presentation because we were
talking about excel but um all
everything i showed that on the on the
presentation day that was all file based
right and there's another type of data
that we didn't get into at all that
would be interesting to do and that's
machine data so things are coming from
databases right so when i built this
presentation i kept thinking about the
data sources i couldn't quite work it
into this presentation but if your data
are coming from excel meaning that the
original source of your data
actually
is excel so somebody got into excel and
inputted the data then
you're in a you're an excel land you're
not in our land i mean that's you're
going to be in excel for quite a while
but if your data source is a database
and you're pulling tables from a
database
then i think the jump to r is actually a
lot easier um and i just
i personally would probably bypass excel
in most cases right i know there's power
query and all that stuff right but if
i'm getting machine data and that's not
just databases but that's like apis
right or some sort of streaming feed
or even just curling information from
the or a w get from the web from a
website all of those things like i would
like start thinking r personally
couldn't quite figure that in the
presentation because the presentation
was very much file based right and when
you have files
i think
figuring out where to go r excel it's
kind of like i got this csv do i open
the csv in r excel i don't know you know
i'll default to excel right that's a
much fuzzier thing but when it's
databases
right color
anyway thanks for watching
no definitely a follow-up question there
was um can our work directly within a
database yes the right guy
so yeah so if you come here to
our studio and we do connections and new
connection here um yeah these are all
the database connections right so
um
probably i don't know if people
use uh snowflake out there but this is a
snowflake connection and uh and then it
will populate
uh right here into the connection window
browse things so let's see if i
open up my maria database for that um
let's see if this is still active
maria is like a floating version of
that postgres
sql
yep oh demo sorry demo
uh test table test table here
oh it's the iris data set
and i'll go ahead and pull that up
there you go so this this iris data are
inside so i'm this is this is inside of
the database here if i want to pull that
data into excel i can do that with the
ddi package or the deploy package
try to make that we've tried to make
that easy for you um
one of my main goals when i joined our
studio was to make that easier
a follow-up question
there nathan was have you ever connected
to any bank portals um
and i know you've worked with a lot of
our financial customers bank portals man
i don't even know what we're talking
about what's a bank portal like banks
keep their data really locked down
we're not getting into the blockchain
are we um well give me an example a bank
portal
uh we work with some banks and uh they
usually have uh
their databases are usually pretty
traditional you're looking like a db2
database or something like that
but um i guess i need more information
she said like bank of america using an
api
yeah well there's lots of ways to
interface with apis
through r um so again i need a little
bit more information but
um
yeah the bank
group the banks the banks are
um those environments are
can be very restrictive right so usually
my experience with the bank it's not the
tools that are the problem it's the
policies that are the problem right so
so um
i think what i've seen a lot of banks do
is make it very difficult to solve
problems right so it's like we can't
solve this problem because we have all
these restrictions right and so what
ends up happening is that um
users kind of find a way to get around
those barriers and those
problems like maybe um they'll just
download the data their desktop you know
and just kind of email that around or
something like stuff but but i'm not
privy to any of that because we don't do
that everything in our studio as an
enterprise software company is all about
board so like the securities decisions
that security conversation comes
that we talked about those all have to
be answered by us because we're assuming
that we're coming through the front door
but my understanding is talking with
people the bank there's a lot of back
door activity going on by the employees
so i guess i need a little bit more
information to
help you uh do a black ops operation
there on your bank portal api calls
and nathan one of the questions on slido
was how can we connect with you to chat
about other topics like enterprise
solutions or architecting
workflows yeah it just brings joy to my
life i i'd love to connect with any of
you
um i let's see the best way to do this
um
my email is nathan
um
rstudio.com
[Music]
i'm on linkedin of course um
i used to have twitter but i've kind of
this is i've kind of uncoupled from
twitter and facebook um so i'd say the
email or the linkedin is probably fine
i'm also on community.org.com you can
find me there too
awesome i see one other question that
came in
from raphael can we connect r directly
for any and i'm assuming this means
database the dd vbb and visualize real
time data
so connecting r to any database and
visualizing real time
i'm not sure what a ddb is i know what a
db is it's a database um so i'm going to
assume that means a database um
raphael uh yes if you want to hook up
like a shiny application to a live
database that is very common we have a
lot of customers doing that and there
are there are some resources online for
doing that
you'll have to make sure you have
permissions to connect to that database
but what you normally do is you run the
shiny application either as yourself or
as a service account that has
permissions to to access that database
and then the tools are you're just going
to use
the same r tools to pull that data in
depending on the user inputs so for
example say i'm a user and i want to
like access my oracle database and i
want to pull in like the latest sales
data you know um i will go in there and
like put a
date range and that date range will pass
through sql and the driver and pull that
data back and populate the shiny
application very very common request
very common use case for shiny
okay ddb is database
okay i lied when i said last question
before
one other question um
anthony lee uh said i'm new to r and the
dopamine rush is so rewarding what's the
the best way to start getting your hands
messy is there a site with cases to
start analyzing data
oh man that's gonna make me cry okay so
um
yes i i i hear you um i i see what you
see um r speaks to me as well right
there are a lot of people that do that i
just tell people that um like i will
just pull up r on the weekend and just
kick around a few ideas in my head i'll
just do it for fun you know i want to
try this thing if you've ever used like
sass
you i can't imagine pulling sass up on
the weekend i don't know any sas user
who sits around saturday morning like i
wonder if sas can do this thing right so
there's there is something special about
r um and if it's speaking to you that
that's fantastic now i lost the question
was it like getting started how do you
get started rachel you can answer that
question
so the question is like where to find um
cases to start with analyzing data but i
do think and jake shared this in the
chat as well
but tidy tuesday i think is a great
project so every week
tuesday
there's a new data set
really so then people kind of visualize
that data and then share it out on
twitter for other people to see
i know a few other people said try
taking a coursera course on r
there's also a lot of great resources at
education.ourstudio.com too
um but yeah if you if anyone has ideas
feel free to put them in the chat too i
think necessity is the mother of
invention for me i like
i wouldn't go out i mean you can go to
kaggle and like do that competition if
you want that could be fun but like
if you have data like that's where
things get really you know that's where
you really get the motivation to do
stuff
so um if you have the opportunity to
seek out that data um and like seek out
a problem that matters that's where you
that's where i learned the most you know
it's like i got a challenge now and it's
real yeah
but tidy tuesday's not sims yesterday
rachel tuesday's really good
i just want to check if there's any
questions that i missed from the zoom
chat
i'm just scrolling through but i don't
know if i missed anything earlier
r for data science yeah there's some
books right yep
link for tidy tuesday
i think it might just be
teddytuesday.com i'm just checking real
quick though
yeah education our studio
yeah i mean i think i think our students
do a nice job of you know expanding the
the ecosystem i mean there's just a lot
of
pieces in the ecosystem now that was
really nice when i was starting art um
it wasn't gonna date me guys but i
started using our pre google okay so
like finding
information about r back then was
almost impossible and then when google
did come out it wasn't smart enough to
distinguish between
like r
the programming language and the letter
r so it's like you put r in there it was
a worthless search you know you'll still
see the issues now with argument
conflated with reddit right um like r
something and sometimes you'll get
reddit as a result so google still
struggles with that but
um
generally speaking
yeah searching out there is going to
return a lot of really great stuff
yeah we'll also just put a plug out
there for our weekly.org as well does a
really nice job of pulling in
blog posts and different materials every
week
yeah yeah there's a lot of stuff a lot
of a lot of
publishing going on matt dancho
mr dancho
daniel
i don't you uh
you must know matt say hi to matt for me
um but also up there i know we kind of
just started off with a an intro so
going
scaling spreadsheets with our but very
specific topics that
you'd want to dive deeper into
i'm gonna just sign nathan up for those
offenses yeah yeah
erin asked if i started with the s
programming language and the answer to
that is yes i did
but i did
include a form there too if you have any
feedback or things that you'd like to
see
i'll try and copy that over again let's
see
but i just want to say thank you so much
nathan that was awesome and i i love
this real honor i i really appreciate
you guys i can't tell you how
appreciative i am of this like i'm i i
feel like this was just a wonderful
opportunity so thank you all thank you
rachel thank you maria
thank you so much maria for
for bringing this idea to us as well and
thank you all for joining
thank you thank you thank you thank you
i think that's just the start we have so
many people going for that virtual
coffee so i think that was awesome
opportunity for to connect not only like
our lovers and like those excel former
lovers but also to connect continents so
that virtual coffee is going to spread
out between australia and u.s
that's that's awesome
yeah definitely and i just said if
people are interested please just email
me directly so i have your email because
meetup doesn't give me people's email
um so i just put my email there
but thank you all so much have a great
day ahead and depending on where you are
so i have my students here so we are
moving on to our class and we have
another half an hour of absolutely
fantastic things to do thank you so much
[Music]
you